there are other human beings on Mars now
coexistence may prove just as
challenging as it does on earth
monetization ultimately looks like an
advanced version both industry is going
to be absolutely vital to that effort
Newcomb's the private corporation
- if there's money to be made then
people would go there to make the money
the Arctic is a perfect example of this
we see companies looking at the Arctic
as a portal for will space is a new
frontier
it's unexplored What's it saying drill
baby drill your crew has cut into a
scientific reserve
what you're doing is not right anytime
science reaches a conclusion you are
going to face pushback history of human
conduct there's plenty of evidence of
things going on there are no real
boundaries here Moz is gonna be more
dangerous there's a contagion going
through the economy their consequences
are gonna be dire for everybody I don't
know what to do the cost of being
foolish is so hard that you will fail
there's one thing worse teaches you it's
patience space exploration brings out
the best in us it's where we solve
problems that have never been solved
before
[Music]
your actions have consequences
[Music]
[Music]